la surprise pour ces élèves du collège
fernand donatien trois classes choisi au
hasard pour une opération de fouilles en
bonne et due forme
à l'arrivée sur ce groupe quelques
combats dans les trousses matériel
pourtant interdit par le règlement
intérieur de l'établissement qui fournit
le matériel
ceci depuis déjà bien trois ans les ça
ne fait pas partie de la liste des
matériels demandé aux élèves ce sont les
établissements scolaires qui achètent
des koopas les ciseaux et qui met à
disposition pendant le cours les parents
devront venir récupérer ce matière y
aller il faudra nécessairement re faire
de la pédagogie sur le règlement en tout
cas et pour faire face à une insécurité
grandissante les autorités décembre 2018
avait décidé de signer une convention
pour permettre ces contrôles objectif
montrer aux parents qu'il y a une
réaction
et puis la nécessité de la prévention
pas seul collectivement dans les
établissements scolaires essentielles en
matière de lutte contre la prolifération
d'armes c'est le discours de la
prévention c'est vraiment cela qui est
attendu de la part du monde enseignant
et c'est ce qu'il faut au jour le jour
mais nous devons être également là pour
appuyer cette communauté scolaire si
utile il faut d'abord que les parents
sachent que
la question de la sécurité de leurs
enfants dans les établissements
scolaires est une préoccupation de
l'académie mais pas que seulement
également les autorités forces de
l'ordre et de la justice
je sais aussi montré que on prend en
charge cette question là parce que c'est
une question qui est indispensable dans
la façon d'apprendre à la fois
d'instruire et d'être instruit le
contrôle à l'intérieur de
l'établissement apprécié aussi à
l'extérieur dans le snack d'en face ce
gérant estime que tout doit être fait
pour la sécurité des jeunes tant que ça
ça donne des avantages sur la sécurité
tant que ça permet aux élèves ainsi
qu'aux enseignants puisque le corps
enseignant aussi dedans aussi bien les
surveillantes les professeurs et cetera
tant que ça peut favoriser la sécurité
effectivement éviter les cas de violence
inattendue oui on est pauvre à fond les
ballons
l'opération de ce matin a déjà permis
une conclusion il faudra multiplier ce
genre de contrôle au minimum sur le
rythme de deux par mois